>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, DC.
>> Nora Krug: We hope you're having
a wondering day, in the heat,
celebrating the joy of reading
here in the National Mall.
Just before we start, I have a
couple of housekeeping measures.
I want to tell you that the pavilion
-- this presentation is being filmed
for the Library of Congress'
website for their archives,
so please be mindful of that
as you enjoy this presentation.
Also please don't sit on the camera
risers in the back of the pavilion.
With that said, I'm Nora Krug.
I write a column for
the Washington Post,
which is another sponsor
of this wonderful event.
And I'm very honored to be here
to introduce James Ransome,
who has illustrated more
than 20 children's books,
including The Creation,
How Many Stars in the Sky,
Sweet Clara, and The Freedom Quilt.
He is a two-time recipient of
the Coretta Scott King award
for illustration for The Creation,
and for Uncle Jed's Barber Shop.
He's also completed
several commissioned murals
for the Children's
Museum in Indianapolis,
and the National Underground
Railroad Freedom Center
in Cincinnati.
Ransome lives in Upstate New
York with his wife, Lisa?
>> Yes.
>> Lisa Cline-Ransome, who is
also a children's book writer.
And the two have collaborated
on several books,
including Satchel Paige, Quilt
Alphabet, Quilt Counting, and Pele.
And amid all of this work they also
have managed to raise four children,
three of whom are now teenagers.
Ransome's latest book is
Gunner, which is a first for him,
as he has both written
and illustrated the book.
We're looking forward to
seeing more of that from him.
And I have the wonderful honor
of saying it's also
his birthday today, so.
[ applause ]
>> James Ransome: Thank you so much.
Well, it's really a
pleasure to be here.
And I feel the same way you
guys feel, I'm hot and tired.
So I'm gonna try to
make this exciting.
I'm gonna -- I'm gonna do a
storytelling of Gunner, my --
my first book that I
wrote and illustrated.
And it's gonna be -- and since
I'm not used to doing this,
as an illustrator I'm used to
doing PowerPoint presentations,
but now I have to sort of tell
the story and flip the pages.
Way too much to do at once,
but I'm gonna give it a shot.
And then after that I'm going to --
I guess I'll answer a few questions,
based on how much time we have left,
I'm watching my time keeper here.
And -- but I really
want to draw with some
of the young people
that are here today.
So I'm going to be inviting kids
to come up to write a number,
and I'm gonna show you how I can
draw with a -- from a number.
I will make sure I turn the pad so
the people on this side can see.
But it's gonna be hard
to accommodate everyone,
cause it's so -- such
a wide area here.
So let's get started
with -- with Gunner.
And first I'd like to
tell you a little bit
about Gunner and how it came about.
I'm a big football fan, and I
-- I grew up in North Carolina.
In 1972 I started watching football.
So I'm a Miami Dolphin fan.
[ applause ]
And I always talk to kids --
somehow I go to the schools,
I end up talking to the
kids about my football team.
There's always usually a
question that comes up.
And I -- it was just
always interesting
to me how some kids just had
this -- this sense of winning.
I mean they -- they would do
anything to win and to want to win.
And I just found that interesting.
So I wanted to -- when it came to
writing this book I wanted to write
about that -- that need and desire
to win, to help kids understand
that we don't always win, and
there's actually two sides
who are -- who are trying to win.
And your story may be compelling,
but maybe a story on the other side
of the field which is just as
compelling as yours to win.
So that's how Gunner came about.
So it starts off with Gunner
is a great name for a boy
who -- who loved football.
He didn't look like
a football player.
He looked -- he was too
short and too round.
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: Gunner was the
only child of Mr. and Mrs. Smith,
who didn't like sports at all.
But they knew their
son liked sports,
and made sure he was the first child
in line when it came to signing
up for the Peewee League
football team.
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: Told
you this would be hard.
Gunner said that he wanted to be
a quarterback, but everyone looked
at him and laughed because he
didn't look like a quarterback.
But when they saw him
throw a -- a foot --
throw a football, they
said oh my God.
The laughing stopped
because he had a great arm.
So they said you can
be a quarterback,
but you can be a third
string quarterback,
but mainly because
of the way he looked,
because he had a much better
arm than all the other players.
So once the season start -- started,
Gunner sat the bench all year long.
He never got a chance to play,
but he was always the first one
at practice, the last one to leave.
On Saturdays he would
watch the college games,
on Sunday he would watch the pros.
He always studied his
book and his plays.
But he sat the bench all year.
But in the last game of the season,
in the Peewee County's championship,
the Mighty Bowl, during the --
in the third quarter when --
in the fourth quarter, I'm
sorry, when his team --
the Malden Tigers -- were down, the
first quarterback was hit and was --
actually someone stepped on
his fingers and he went home.
And then the second string
quarterback came in, and he was hit
so hard he saw stars, and his
mommy took him to the hospital.
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: But no one --
no one was excited when
Gunner went into the game.
Actually everyone was pretty quiet.
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: And no
one was especially excited
when he ran the wrong way on the
first play and he was sacked.
But his parents cheered, go Gunner!
But everyone cheered after he threw
his first touchdown, a spiral,
to a -- a tight -- a wide
receiver in the end zone.
So they were two scores down, and
he had to score one more time.
The defense got the ball
back, and Gunner went back in,
and again his parents
cheered, go Gunner!
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: Well everyone
cheered once again once he scored.
He threw a long bomb
for a touchdown,
and now the game was tied.
And everyone was excited when Gunner
went back into -- onto the field.
His father -- his coach
said you can win this game.
We can win the championship,
we just need one more score.
They only had minutes
left in the game.
The team -- the offense slowly
moved down the field, the --
the running backs ran, the receivers
caught, and they slowly moved
down towards the end zone.
But everyone was surprised when
Gunner tried to throw a pass
to his wide receiver,
and the defensive back
from the other team
intercepted the ball,
and ran it in for a
touchdown, and won the game.
So Gunner's team didn't win,
but they still carried
him off the field,
'cause they felt he tried his
hardest, and he was a hero to them.
And after the game they
went out for ice cream,
and his coach gave him
rookie of the year trophy.
And -- and everyone
gave him a high five
in the -- in the ice cream parlor.
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: The next
morning while having breakfast,
Gunner's father was
reading the newspaper.
He read that a little
girl from across town
on the Woodland [phonetic] team
intercepted the ball and ran it
in for a touchdown, and
it was her first time
in the game playing for her team.
And that's the story of
Gunner, our football hero.
[ applause ]
>> James Ransome: So
Gunner is a hero,
although he did not win the game.
And we can all be heroes
without always coming in first.
There's lots of things
we can accomplish,
lots of challenges we can
overcome, and still be successful.
Sometimes it's -- I
know it sounds cliche,
but sometimes it's something
more important than being the one
with the highest score,
or actually the one
who walks away with
the championship.
There are other small challenges
that we can be winners at.
So that's what I wanted
to do about Gunner.
And the idea about this little
girl who it was her first time in,
no one knows anything
about her until she gets in
and she scores the touch --
winning touchdown for her team.
I just felt that that was a very
interesting, compelling story
that I wanted to tell, built around
Gunner, this football player.
Are there any other -- are
there any questions about Gunner
that I could answer, quickly?
I could tell you guys some
things about how I got started
as an illustrator, if not.
But on Gunner?
We could talk about --
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: Yes,
microphone please.
>> I wonder if you would
have any advice to give sort
of a beginning children's
book writer?
You know, we're told different
things, you know, about how --
how the text and the --
and the illustrations
are supposed to interact.
Can you -- can you --
>> James Ransome: As
-- as -- as a writer?
Or as illustrator?
>> Yeah, what would
you -- what you say
as an illustrator to
a beginning writer?
>> James Ransome: What would I say
to an illustrator as
a beginning writer?
That's -- that's a good way to
phrase it, 'cause I don't feel
like I'm really a writer yet.
I would say write your story, and
try to sell your story, and don't --
don't -- although you should leave
something to the illustrator.
And that's probably the
hardest part for early writer,
is those parts you lead to -- you
live -- you give to an illustrator.
You want to sort of set the
illustrator up, and give him clues
to what's in your imagination
if -- if that --
if that helps, rather
than being direct
and telling him the person has
on let's say boots, for example.
If you want the character to have on
boots, maybe you can say something
about putting the boots on, how
you put the boots on, rather than,
you know, the person
just has on boots.
It's things like that.
It's sort of -- I love
when -- when --
when writers just give me
great clues for visual images.
And I think that's -- that's
what I look for in stories.
And also sometimes how they leave
certain things for me to add.
I always think of it as it's
ice cream, and it's my job
to put the sprinkles on the top.
The text is the ice cream,
and I put the sprinkles on top
of the ice cream, that's
what I try to do.
So I don't want you to give
me all the information,
I want you to just -- just
sort of create a pathway for me
to walk down, as the artist, okay?
Some people wonder -- and this is
actually a good question writing
and illustrating -- how did I --
how did I get to be here today,
talking about my books, and I've
illustrated almost 50 books to date.
I was a young boy, I'm growing up
in a small town in North Carolina.
In this small town I came from there
were not a lot of opportunities
for me, someone who wanted to be
an artist since the third grade.
Art wasn't even taught in
the schools I attended,
and there were no artists to be
around to take me to their studios,
or even go to museums
to see artwork.
So my first things that inspired
me were comic books, and --
and cartoons on television,
like so many kids.
I started drawing at a very early
age, as well as writing stories.
I wrote stories to give me
a reason to draw pictures.
Then I became influence by Mad
magazine, and I would copy stories
in Mad magazine, and I would draw
images from there and make up books
about my friends and I
doing different things.
I basically would pass
those out in the classroom.
From -- once I got into high school,
I started drawing less and less.
But at that same time I moved
from North Carolina to New Jersey,
and I was really fortunate
to move into a school system
that had a great art department.
It was just the opposite of where
I had grew up in North Carolina.
It was Bergenfield, New Jersey.
And there they had -- we had
eight art teachers at one point.
And anything you could
imagine was offered at this --
in this school setting --
this public school setting.
I spent a lot of my time
with my other passion,
which was film making.
I wanted to be a film maker, so I --
I made films, and this
was back in the days
when you actually used film, it
wasn't video, it wasn't digital.
We used to actually develop our own
black and white film, so it was --
it was very difficult because
you would do -- make --
do all this work to film the
film, then you went to develop it
and you would ruin
it in developing it.
And then if you didn't ruin it then,
you would probably ruin it trying
to put the sound strip on.
Because you had to use glue,
and the film would move around
and you glued this piece
of tape to the film,
and it would easily
go across the film.
So a lot of great films
were ruined there.
So I -- I just recently went back to
my old high school and was talking
to my high school film
making teacher.
And these kids today
have it so easy.
I mean they -- they actually
made a film the day before his
retirement party.
And some of the older people
like myself were there,
and we just shook our heads
going we could have never done
that back when we were in school.
So I was very fortunate
when it was time to go
to college I started animating my
films, because I did like working
by myself, I didn't like
working for a large group.
As a film maker you do have
to work with a lot of people.
So I started animating my film,
and that brought me back
to drawing and painting.
Then I went to college and decided
to major in illustration, and --
and in illustration I fell in
love with drawing and painting.
And that's when I sort of focused my
-- all my energies on illustrating,
and it's that drawing and painting
which has gotten me
into children's books.
While at private institute I met
Jerry Pinkley's [phonetic] son,
who was attending school there.
His name was Scott [phonetic] -- not
Brian [phonetic], the illustrator.
And Scott brought his
father in to speak to us,
and after I graduated I reconnected
with Jerry, and we create --
and basically over a long period
of time a friendship developed,
with me going up to see him
and talking about my artwork.
So that's my long journey
to -- to getting here.
I was very fortunate to be in some
right places at the right time,
but it also is a path of a lot
of -- of a lot of hard work.
I worked extremely hard
when I was in art school
to develop a good portfolio
that got me my first book job
within two years after graduating,
and I've been doing
books ever since.
And they've gotten better and
better, and now I'm doing books
with my wife who's a
writer, Lisa Cline-Ransome.
And we've collaborated on
maybe five or six books.
It's hard to keep count because
some books are in production
when some books are just coming out.
And now I've written my first book
that I've written and illustrated.
So it's been a wonderful journey,
and I've enjoyed every minute of it,
and really appreciate my wife
who tolerates my long hours
in the studio, along with my four
children who also are very patient
and understanding with me being in
the studio for lots of long hours.
So now -- I haven't seen
the sign yet, I'm not --
so I'm not at that 10
minute point, okay?
So good. So if you guys wouldn't
mind, I would like to draw,
which is one of my
favorite things to do.
And I'd like to get some
of you to help me draw.
I like to show people
how easy drawing can be,
and how you don't have
to go to school to draw.
Anyone can draw, as long
as you can see shapes.
So I'm gonna ask some kids to come
up here and create some nice shapes
that we all know, and those
are numbers between 1 and 10.
So if I can get some --
a volunteer to come up
and write a nice big number on
this paper, any number they want
between 1 and 10, I'm gonna
show you how I can make
that number into an image.
And I think this young lady over
here is gonna be my first volunteer.
We're gonna have to --
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: The number 9,
which happens to be my favorite
number to draw with, okay?
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: This
is my favorite part.
[ silence ]
[ applause ]
>> James Ransome: Next person?
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: Between 1 and 10.
Oh and -- oh.
I'm getting all my favorite
numbers first, that's great.
I didn't staff the audience either.
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: A magician.
[ applause ]
[ silence ]
>> Baseball player.
[ applause ]
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: A pirate.
[ applause ]
[ silence ]
>> James Ransome: This is
our last number, number 2.
Okay, good job.
[ silence ]
[ applause ]
>> James Ransome: Okay.
Are there any questions
about anything?
We have two minutes left.
Yes, to the mic?
Could you come to the mic please?
>> [Inaudible].
>> James Ransome: Oh.
>> Yes, I am.
I drew a lot as a kid.
I've always liked doodling, I've
always liked making pictures.
I -- actually when I think
back and I talk to my --
some of my childhood friends, I
was always the one who was sort
of coming up with new games
and things to play with.
So yeah, I was that way growing up.
And you are -- you can really
get your voice across the room.
[ laughter ]
Yes.
>> [Inaudible].
What do you think is like more fun?
Or what do you --
>> James Ransome: Well --
>> -- enjoy --
>> -- more?
>> James Ransome: It's always
fun playing with words.
That's -- that's --
that's a challenge
and interesting about writing.
But I still like drawing
and making the pictures.
That's still the thing I enjoy
most, working with colors
and compositions, and
placing figures
in a space is always fun to me.
>> Okay. Can I do another one?
>> James Ransome: Sure, why not?
Yeah.
>> Are you gonna be
writing more books?
>> James Ransome: Yes, I am.
There are gonna be more
books coming from me, yes.
>> Okay.
>> James Ransome: Yeah.
Thank you.
>> Thank you.
>> James Ransome: Yes.
>> I assume you like
what you're doing,
so you're living your
dream basically.
I was wondering if there's something
that you can't do right now
but you -- that's a challenge for
you that you would really love
to do, that you're working
towards, that's kind of your dream
that you're not able to do right now
but you'd like to do in the future?
>> James Ransome: That's a
very interesting question.
There is. I'm interested
in painting,
doing more gallery paintings.
That would be my ultimate
dream to do that.
So that's something I'm
-- I'm working towards.
But I do feel very fortunate
that my dream did come true,
to be able to -- to make a living
off of the art that I create.
I feel very fortunate.
That would be the other
dream I would have.
>> What do you like drawing
better, animals or people?
>> James Ransome: Animals --
people are what I enjoy most.
I consider myself a
figurative painter.
Painting people is much more
challenging, especially facial
and facial expressions
are so much fun.
Animals are good, but, you know,
you can sort of get away with more
with animals 'cause most
of us don't know animals
that well, so it's a little easier.
Over time, oh.
I'm over time.
So my time is up.
I'd like to thank you
for coming out today.
[ background applause ]
>> James Ransome: I
really appreciate it.
Bye-bye.
[ applause ]
[ silence ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.